it's a such an honor to be involved in
the this evenings amazing launch for
something so important if you're a
neuroscientist who wants to understand
how the brain works and what you can do
to make life better for people for whom
the brain is a challenge in a certain
way there is not a better place on earth
that you can work than MIT in the
McGovern Institute and the addition of
this amazing Youth Center for autism
research makes it you know just you know
it's on our shoulders to do something
really really valuable and thank you so
much for for making this opportunity so
you've heard amazing talks three in a
row from outstanding scientists linking
genes to neurons to mice and marmosets
and of course our the long-term goal is
to use as a fantastic neuroscience to
help people and so for those of us who
work on humans adults and children we
have the advantage that we work on the
species that we want to help and care
about and love and our families and
society we have the disadvantage that
you know we're very limited in what we
can do in terms of developing new
technologies we can innovate to be very
safe and cautious at the McGovern
Institute thanks to a brain imaging
center what we can do with humans
infants through through through adults
is remarkable compared to what it was
when I was a graduate student MIT in the
1980s we could do nothing to look inside
the really in the mind of a brain the
brain of a of a child or an adult in any
serious way and now we have downstairs
thanks to the McGovern Institute the
Martinez Imaging Center and unopened
philanthropy and grants an amazing array
of tools that measure the structure and
function of the brain both temporally
how quickly operates and structurally as
its organization and I'm going to focus
tonight on one method that's maybe our
most powerful method but they're all
powerful and valuable magnetic MRI or
neural imaging which can show us things
about the gray matter structure of the
brain the white matter organization that
the super information highways of the
brain as well as brain function which
parts of the brain turn on what's the
sort of mental life that's supported by
the biology of the brain and because we
do a lot of work with children
downstairs we
for example this fake MRI scanner uh-huh
because I fake news but it's a fake
scanner it's um you know it to get
children to be comfortable with the
environment to be under back your noise
to push buttons while they're on their
back because we know that for our
science to be successful we have to have
a session that's very gentle and benign
to families and children and so this
gives the children all the time they
want and children with autism often are
uncomfortable and novel settings and so
we give them all the time they want to
get comfortable prepared to have a good
session in the scanner across the hall
and I can tell you that we often get
amazing notes from children's as
spontaneous note we get tons as we get
lots of these uh so here's a child who
wrote she draws a noisy scanner can I do
that again and she writes the graduate
student you work with you've let me have
more fun in three days and I could have
in any other place just think of it I'm
playing a game we describe the
experiments with games wide open at the
same time I'm a research guinea pig if
you're a tough grader you know you could
pick up two points and who knows I might
help someone else my age if they have
any brain problems while still earning
money hahaha
this is almost the ethos of the
scientists right but it's a small amount
a modest amount of money goes to the
parent as a thank you for all research
participants that we do and what do you
think beats that nothing it's sort of
the beautiful spontaneous language of a
child and so I've worked for many years
and I'm looking at children and their
developments under the verses dealer
development and I think that all infants
are born into a neurobiological lottery
where the genes are born with and the
environment they're born into will make
life either easier or harder for them in
a variety of ways and as members of
society as parents as siblings as
clinicians or researchers we want to
sort of maximize the ways in which all
these children can flourish whatever
hand they're dealt we want to make the
world as good for them as possible
and we know that so many children face
challenges the numbers are pretty
remarkable right so I work in a number
of these fields but in dyslexia about
10% of children struggle to learn basic
reading the current numbers in the u.s.
for ADHD are about 10% autism as you
know the rates of autism are much higher
now there's
lot of issues about how to think about
that but there's a lot of children who
need help one in 42 boys is the current
estimate in United States special
education in schools one out of eight
children in US schools receive special
education for one reason or another
poverty in the u.s. at different stories
in different countries 32 percent of
children are estimated under 18 to be in
families that have such low incomes half
of the children in public schools in the
u.s. qualify for free and reduced public
lunch because of low family income and
of course all these things mix together
I mean their children can be born into
better or less supportive environments
and have these difficulties or
challenges and so a lot of children who
need a lot of help and I'm a huge
believer in neurodiversity I mean one of
the most challenging thing for
scientists who study the brain has been
it turns out that um people are
incredibly diverse whether they have a
label or not this has been a huge source
of frustration for people working on
both genetics and neuroscience you know
but you could just have identical mice
yeah in every family we could make a
huge progress I mean if you would have
said in the 1980s when I was a graduate
student here what am I doing - I'm
creating a double sound so right now
okay let's re if you would have said I'm
quite too close to that if you would
have said to 1980s
the amazing Human Genome Project
advances we've had and the amazing
advances of neuro imaging how little
those advances have yet touched the
lives of people who need help you would
have been considered to be a you know
very cranky pessimist
now I'm not because I think there's
amazing things just around the corner
because of the science you heard about
today but if a lot of that challenge has
been the shocking variety that we now
know underlies human brains its kind of
beautiful actually you know we can't be
reduced to simple stories of genes and
brain pathways where incredibly complex
all of us
genetics experience what age we are what
sex we are what culture we grow up and
personality all of these things turn out
to be huge sources of human diversity in
the mind and brain and that was
recognized you know first and foremost
in many ways an autism spectrum disorder
we would realize it's such a spectrum
such a diversity that shares social and
communication difficulties as
degree of repetitive behaviors and as
you know distinctions that people
thought just a few years ago we're kind
of useful have been wiped away in the
recent psychic psychiatric community not
because there's not huge diversity but
the boundaries of this are very unclear
and so rather than pretend that we just
know the story we just know there's
tremendous diversity and this one child
and one adult at a time so I'm going to
talk a little bit about human research
at MIT from some of my colleagues and
just a couple thoughts about future
directions so this is work from Nancy
kanwisher and Carolyn Robertson showing
one way to approach the human brain in
autism and they focused on gaba an
inhibitory signaling neurotransmitter
and you heard actually from Gloria about
how important it is to have enough
inhibition the right balance of
inhibition and excitation is really
important and using a method called
magnetic resonance spectroscopy or Mrs
Carolina and Nancy and her colleagues
focus in on gaba so mrs gives you
information about the amount of a
certain chemical that's located in a
certain part of the brain and what they
discovered was this that they saw they
saw behavioral differences and people
with or without autism those differences
in visual function correlated with their
severity of their clinical difficulties
who was tied in to the clinical issues
and then when they looked at gaba in
this part of the brain they saw this
difference between people with or
without autism and it was somewhat
specific because when they looked at
another neurotransmitter glutamate they
didn't see that difference so this is
beautiful because it's a nonverbal
translatable paradigm that could be done
with animals there's no no I happen to
study dyslexia I like books and reading
but uh but you know those kinds anything
to do with language we won't be able to
look at in animal models very easily but
simple visual processes are highly
capable of being with that across
species this is work from Pavan Sinha
and he's developed an idea that some
people with autism have difficulty
predicting what comes next they don't
get don't get comfortable with
regularities and so here's an example of
a child
typical typical developing individual
when they hear a sound over and over
again they call habituate to go I've
heard that I've heard that it's not a
big deal they calm down if you want to
call that they've heard the stimulus a
lot here is a child with autism do
exactly the opposite direction being
more and more perturbed by the repeated
sounds or hearing and so you know that
so that's a thought about some of the
sensory difficulties that some people
with autism report now this is work that
I've done in collaboration with Rebecca
Saxe a colleague here two of our
postdocs work together the four of us
and Rebecca has been a leader in
thinking about the brain basis of the
theory of mine so many of you heard
about theory of mine but let me remind
you for those of you who don't live in
this that part of the psychological
world so the ability of mind is the
ability to attribute mental space such
as beliefs intentions and desires to
yourself and others and to understand
that others have beliefs desires and
intentions that are different from one's
own children develop theory of mind
understanding that you as an adult or
their parent or a sibling have thoughts
that can be different from the child's
very slowly if you've ever played
hide-and-seek with a very young child
who does not imagine what you are seeing
and thinking it's pretty easy to catch
them right they like they do like this
and you go no you're still there and
then that then they go like this and
then oh I can still see you right
because they don't understand what
you're thinking what you can see very
easily by but our ability to interact
with other people depends on having an
understanding what other people are
thinking even if it's different than
what we're thinking and much of the
science about how this develops and
young children was built around one task
with a person an evil person named Dan
who's all pretend and a nice person who
Sally so Sally's in one room and she hai
puts the ball under this blanket and
then Sally leaves the room and comes in
and mischievously moves the ball from
under that blanket into the box and
closes the box now Sally comes back in
the room and a three-year-old has asked
where will she look for the ball and the
three-year-old who knows the ball is
here doesn't understand that
Sally can have a different thought in
her head than the physical reality the
child knows and will say Sally will look
here even though there's no reason for
her to look there at all so she doesn't
understand that we all do that
people around us don't understand what's
correct even when we do okay but if you
move to five years old the child will
correctly understand that Sally believes
the ball will be here even though it's
an incorrect belief a person can have an
incorrect belief that's different from
physical reality so that's theory of
mine understanding what's in the mind of
another regardless of whether it's the
same thing that you know or not now it's
been found many times the false beliefs
this idea understanding somebody else
kind of a wrong idea in their head by
about age five and neurotypical children
they understand that children with
autism typically is huge range wait
until about age ten until they can
succeed on such a task at huge range but
there was a mystery that we addressed
which is that adults with ASD often say
this is a challenge for them or their
family says it's hard they'd have a hard
time understanding what other people at
in the workplace or at home what they're
thinking compared to what the individual
is thinking they have worked on reading
other minds but if you take if you test
an adult on this sally-ann task
practically everybody with autism you
know past eighteen aces it okay so that
we had a disconnect between a scientific
approach developed for children and then
adult experience that's commonly felt on
everyday life and so we adopted another
task that involves also some evil and
even death uh so we compared how do you
forgive people when they something bad
happens whether they had good intentions
or not and so so here's the two critical
cases there's a person and you go in and
have coffee with her and with this evil
intention she puts poisoned sugar into
your coffee and you perish okay we all
agree that that's bad right as a bad
person doing a bad thing but what about
is that what about it the same person
inadvertently put some sugar into your
coffee that's poisonous but she didn't
know that how morally culpable is that
person how much do we blame that person
well we think differently because they
had a certain belief the sugar was you
know okay but still there was an outcome
so so in this study with adults with
with or without autism we had the [ __ ]
they judged how bad something was so
everybody agreed that if you went in
somebody served you coffee nothing
happened no bad intentions no bad
outcomes that was
okay everybody agreed that if somebody
on purpose tried to murder you and
succeeded that was terrible
completely the same judgments wither
with it without on it everything but
here's a place where where individuals
look different with or without autism so
what happens if the intention was
neutral that is you were just putting
sugar in you didn't intend to do
anything bad but by mistake the sugar
was poisoned then individuals who are
typically developing were more forgiving
than people with autism now that's not a
right or wrong answer about that okay
and we have athleticism for that
sometimes we say the road to hell is
paved with good intentions that's the
message that if you do something bad it
doesn't count if you say that gives kind
of meaning to do the right thing right
or we say it's the thought that counts
right so we know that both of these
things it's done a right or wrong answer
there's a different perspective on this
and we found this difference and Rebecca
went back and did neuroimaging studies
and found it in this area that's really
important for the for this kind of
theory of mind the right temporoparietal
junction here that you found different
patterns of activation and adults with
or without autism performing as they
exactly this task now where are some
future directions that we can go and so
one of them I think builds very much in
the talks you heard before the more we
understand about the fundamental
neurobiological diversity that's caught
within the broad spectrum of autism
spectrum disorder the more we could go
back to humans and say what looks
different in the brain or behavior if
you have this genetic variant adaption
tech variant the difference in the brain
that are developed in models in mice and
marmosets so we think that's a huge area
is to understand the diversity within
autism spectrum disorders and the second
thing outside the word about it is how
quickly can we move to helping people I
think you know the Bob doesn't must come
in at the beginning and I think other
comments as well the brain is so
complicated that we have to play the
long game you know in my team the
government Institute and the new Center
have to play the long game because it's
a it's a challenge that has to be
thought through at the same time I'm
thinking that we might be able also to
think about how to make life you know
10% or 15% better for people in the near
future that can also be a goal and the
to these goals can be coupled so we
one direction that we're involved in the
middle of a study I can't tell you the
findings because we're in the middle of
it and it's what's called a double-blind
study we're not allowed to know who's in
what condition to keep it up as
objective as possible but here's the
thought
we know that oxytocin is a hormone
associated with pro-social affiliative
behavior in animals and humans
it makes people nicer in many
experiments okay they're more trusting
in games if you play economic games and
things like that mix in nicer and
there's some complications to that but
basically a study after study it reduces
the response to negative stimuli so
here's an MRI study a functional MRI
study from NIH people on placebo
responding in their amygdala to negative
facial expressions and not so much of a
response once they have the medication
and a number of studies in people with
autism showing alterations and brain
responses when they get oxytocin
compared to a placebo so so so there's a
number of reasons to think furthermore
in autism there's a typicality in the
oxytocin system for example a number of
studies that were reported reduced
plasma levels and in meta-analysis
looking over many studies although far
from complete across multiple studies
suppose supporting individuals with
autism and accurate emotion recognition
and useful I guess although there's a
paucity of study of women that's because
not only the dominance of men in the
population with autism but on top of
that because oxytocin is a hormone and
interacting complicated ways with with
naturally a [ __ ] waiting hormones and
people have been shy to take on that
challenge research wise but they don't
have to be so we're involved in a study
that works like this now trying to
understand both some things of the
biology but also this goal of making
life 10 to 15 percent better for people
in the near-term future so my colleague
o Tennant at Mass General Hospital has
developed a social behavioral therapy
program these are coaching sessions
basically where you go in there's a
program that's set up and very
systematically in one-on-one coaching
sessions young adults with autism who
don't have many sources of support in
many situations are coached how to be
more comfortable interacting in the
workplace and social situations and so
on before the
coaching sessions half of the
participants get a dose of a nasally
administered spray it's fruits in the
nose oxytocin and the idea is that they
would be more hopefully because of a
question they'll be more comfortable in
those coaching sessions with the coach
to actually talk about their feelings
and social skills and so on that it
might be my prime the pump so to speak
to benefit from those coaching
interactions and then we're doing MRI
MIT before they go in there because we
want to understand who responds to the
treatment we think our support we think
that on as I think do many in the field
there's a justice as a tremendous
diversity within autism spectrum
disorders so there will be in response
to any given support at least for the
near term future is not as if one
support is going to work for the vast
majority of patients but if a support
work for let's say 30 percent of
individuals pretty well well if you did
the group statistic that we normally do
for evaluating something you'd say it
didn't work because a third of people
responding to something will be
concluded as a failure but if we
understood who those one-third of people
are and then went back and did it again
and show that we know who those
one-third of people are and we could
help them then it'd be phenomenal right
so you know we want to know this is help
does the oxytocin enhance the
effectiveness and can we use brain
measures or genetic measures to
understand who will benefit from this
approach then use that approach with
those kinds of individuals we have
different approaches for the other
individuals so in conclusion were
grateful differ for the Center for
autism research to understand better in
humans the neural mechanisms of autism
and hopefully to accelerate support of
interventions or support that will make
life better in the near term as dramatic
progress occurs in the kind of research
you heard about earlier this evening
thank you very much
[Applause]